j'ai fait des machines en fait au niveau
de mon vagin genre de la radiofréquence
et seva lot la mésothérapie sans un show
sans injection est en fait c'est un
rajeuni le vagin genre c'est trop bien
pour moi j'ai de la chance c'est
vraiment un bon agent jorge pas les
lèvres pourquoi qui dépasse mais il faut
l'entretenir
du coup c'est trop bien genre la passe
comme si j'avais tout sans jour
voilà donc des propos qui ont
extrêmement choquée surtout la dernière
phrase c'est comme si j'avais 12 ans
genre êtes vous choqué par ces
déclarations
on aura l'avocate damaye vague à l'âme
dans un instant pour le moment la sydney
ohana remercie aussi donné d'être là
vraiment c'est un des plus grands
chirurgiens esthétiques et c'est un ami
que j'aime énormément merci signer
d'être là et merci à laurent alexandre
merci d'être là moule rond voilà ça je
sais que tu as été extrêmement choqué
par les propos alors ici non vous vous
dites non non je trouve pas que ses
propos soient dangereux c'est son choix
et ce choix c'est le méchant les amis je
crois que ça a été c'était quelque chose
de très recherché depuis de longues
années essayez de prendre cette décision
je pense que c'est une bonne décision je
vois pas ce qui est dangereux mais ça
n'a rien à voir là vous êtes à côté du
sujet on parle excusez moi nicolas soir
je crois que
[Rires]
je crois que jamais votre cerveau c'est
encore sa as
on passe ce qui a choqué c'est quand à
la vie j'ai l'impression c'est comme si
j'avais 12 ans emballé le times oui moi
là je n'en veux pas à cette jeune fille
est d'ailleurs elle a rétropédalé en
disant qu à s'excuser kim alors on va
voir la vidéo dans un instant mais mais
évidemment que c'est dangereux de dire
des choses comme ça parce que d'abord de
comparer de dire qu'un voisin de 12 ans
pour une femme de 20 ans et c'est
formidable moi ça me met mal à l'aise
parce que je me dis que évidemment ça va
peut-être réveiller des instincts
pédophiles mais si pardon excusez moi il
n'y a rien de normal quand pour un type
de 20 ans et plus de troupes d'avoir
envie d'avoir une femme de 12 ans il n'y
a pas un vrai de vrai premières choses
qui sont d une chose ça veut dire que
aussi on stéréotypes alors on avait
stéréotypes et le visage les saints la
forme maintenant on va jusque dans
l'intimé est très joli mais il va bien
sûr mais on va jusque dans l'intimé
parce qu'il faut ressembler
éventuellement à des vedettes de portes
du porno et c'est parce qu'on mêmes
stéréotypes et l' or une femme elle a le
droit d'avoir dessin asymétrique elle a
droit d'avoir de la cellulite elle a
besoin d'avoir un vagin et maintenant on
a le droit ne pas avoir de couilles à
regarder
que certaines aient recours parce que
c'est des problèmes gynécologiques qui
sont parfois handicapant qu'on puisse
pas faire de sport etc pourquoi pas mais
il faut faire attention je ne je ne
tombe pas sur cette jeune fille parce
que je pense que ses mots ont dépassé sa
pensée et que je ne la croit volontiers
quand elle dit que voilà qu'elle a
qu'elle n'a pas l'air trop vite bon on
verra ses excuses juste après vous
gagnez vous n'êtes pas d'accord alors
déjà à quel moment maeva a dit que qu'il
fallait pas qu'il fallait être imberbe
qu'il fallait avoir des poils a là rien
dit alors juste donné un modèle à la
donne et se souvenir des jeunes tu as
d'autres modèles d'influencé qui vont te
dire il faut garder des poils y en a
beaucoup maintenant sur les réseaux oui
à la parler en son nom
c'est bien toi ou valérie laissez jamais
en son nom mais les six points dans la
vidéo mais coûte à la divine moi je moi
je moi je après pour ce qu'il s'agit du
médical là elle a pas du tout comme tu
penses elle n'a pas fait une opération
nicolas elle a fait un truc c'est de la
mésothérapie c'est pour rajeunir un peu
sa peau donc on rajeunit la peau du
visage comme celle du vagin elle l'a dit
librement et je vois pas où est le
problème vous savez mais mon de femmes
qui souffrent de leur vagin et ça on
n'en parle pas mais france parce que
c'est changer et il ya des gens évitent
des années avec des vagins qui les gêne
on peut parler si on en parle
ouvertement maintenant ce soir on le
fait il ya des dames si on parle des
lèvres qui tombe jusqu'aux cuisses c'est
bon
je suis désolé mais y aller pas le
second qui en souffrent toutes les
revues et justement grâce à ce genre de
vidéo on peut y voir un truc positif
malgré la maladresse je commence a été
annoncée par maybach je suis d'accord
mais sachez que ça peut sauver
énormément de femmes dans leur vie
d'aller voir un gynéco et de se dire bah
ouais peut-être que je traîne sans moi
ils me rendent chez un chirurgien
esthétique que je le recevrais ouais
ouais je peux aller voir mon gynéco ou
mon chirurgie esthétique pour me rendre
compte que et ben en fait quand je fais
du sport je peux ne pas être gêné quand
je fais l'amour je ne pas avoir mal bon
chabrol le dire
moi c'est bon c'est bon je pense que oui
mais ça va c'est pas parce que
d'habitude elle fait un peu la dengue au
qu'elle peut pas aussi parler de choses
sérieusement l'aladi de manière très
maladroite c'est ça qui est désespérant
parce qu'on peut aller parler d'une
enfant de 12 ans mais elle a ouvert le
dialogue pour les femmes qui peuvent
souffrir des landes saussines mais voilà
alors on l a évoqué le voile a eu
d'accord avec elle
est déjà venue voir maeva je ne braderai
pas d'accord sur la maladresse de maeva
ghanam on est tous d'accord y compris l
wen quel est l'intérêt de cette
maladresse et est ce qu'on peut en tirer
quelque chose de bénéfique et positive
je fais juste un recul il ya un siècle
on se raser pas nature en soirée c'est
pas quand la mode du rasage est apparu
que fassent les ou de haut niveau de
langue non
[Rires]
est apparu est bien là il veut
on a été découverte riez vous pouvez
rien il ya une grande confusion entre le
vagin et la vue j'ai l'impression qu'on
parle pas de la même chose est vraie la
vulve tout ce que l'on voit deux faces
c'est simplement les grandes lèvres
délai de cinq ans merci c'est la porte
d'entrée forcément
y'a pas un leader devant
si vous me montrez le coc vide très bien
d'accord oui c'est bien mais le vagin
n'a jamais été vraiment
oui oui mais d'accord salalah elle n'en
parle pas c'est une erreur confond les
mac os x par la rue dit elle même
qu'elle confond qu'elle a pas fait
d'études qu'elle confond donc oublions
le problème de l'agencé quelque chose de
touchant faire en oublie maintenant la
vulve c'est vrai que c'est rentré dans
la représentation sexuelle sensuelle des
couples et même des jeunes qui voient
des bulls dans les télés dans les images
en tout ça n'existait pas avant puisque
avait des poils option alors faut-il
certaines découvre à travers ça qu'elles
ont ou des petites lèvres de foot
important essai des complexes et des
complexes et les mamans qui les amène
non n'imaginait pas la fille de 12 ans
qui vient consulter tout seul c'est la
mère qui dépensent à quissac la gambie
est ce que c'est normal que c'est pas
normal il faut répondre à cette
inquiétude et le reste c'est ailleurs le
grandes lèvres qu'il faut remplir en
plus volumineuse hydratée c'est ce qu'a
fait maeva important simplement les
petits traitement avec la radiofréquence
ou une petite injection d'accord
d'accord
il va alors vaut pas que de leurs mots
il retrouvé que ça vous plaira pas
choquer des annonces ne serait qu'un
déferlement c'est vraiment le sujet du
jour gergy statique ça a toujours existé
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ces jeunes filles
elle est là
elle en parle c'est tout après après
pardon mais si rajeunir son vagin à dire
avoir un vagin de 12 ans pour vous c'est
un appel au viol posez-vous des vraies
questions dans vos têtes c'est bouclé
c'est de finir c'est que c'est vous qui
avez un problème parce qu'à aucun moment
ci ont néanmoins normalement constitué
un vagin de 12 ans c'est un appel au
viol ou c'est excitant je vois je n'ai
même pas compris le produire oui pardon
c'est parce que taylor non mais laissez
le finira par dubaï que tu normal elle
est normale elle s'expliquer auprès des
gens normaux ce que tu es vraiment si je
n'ai même pas compris où était la chose
publique voilà l aval inculpé maintenant
qu'est plus ferme qui est très bien
bandelettes répondent à
une veine de vue qui est plus ferme avec
des lèvres plus pu le maire du mas de
grille
mais en tous les cas encore une fois
associés la pédophilie un vase un de 12
ans se trouve que vraiment c'est
extrêmement gras alors la tête de ceux
qui font cet amas guerre on en rigole
mais il ya eu vraiment c'est une très
très grosse polémique ce week-end
laurent alexandre par exemple il est
outré un nom mais je pense qu'il faut
faire attention elle est suivie par 3
million deux cent mille jeunes et
principalement des jeunes filles
internalise des ados des pré ados et des
jeunes filles donc il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit elle à une
audience qui est trois fois l'audience
une grosse émission de télévision mme
anne donc elle a une influence massive
c'est un modèle pour les jeunes c'est un
modèle de réussite il faut savoir que
rien que son activité sur les réseaux
sociaux il gagne 150 milles par mois
d'ailleurs on la voit que je fous là sur
instagram on se demande j'allais me
refaire la bulle
vacances maeva il part en vacances on
falcon jet privé
excellent souvenir au réseau a parlé une
seconde sur l'importance qu'elle est un
modèle de réussite donc il faut il a
bossé lyon à ce qu'elle dit c'est pas la
rue lcl s'est excusé elle a dit qu'elle
était allée trop loin alors justement
qu'elle a confondu le vagin et la bulle
parce qu'on ne l'a jamais fait
d'opérations sur le vagin sydney tu as
tout à fait raison on a on a regardé que
la vue lui on a fait c'est pas de la
chirurgie esthétique c'est quoi un taux
de la médecine esthétique ouais on lui a
fait un petit peu de mésothérapie donc
en réalité on lui a rien fait mais elle
a une influence et je voudrais quand
même dire que à l'adolescence les
gamines sont très influencés par les
influences alain sueur et et les
influenceurs et donc de deux centres et
donner des angoisses aux gamines sur
leur vagin ça peut être dangereux et on
sait d'ailleurs qu'à l'adolescence la
dysmorphophobie c'est-à-dire
l'impression de bizarreries de son corps
c'est la 10 sport nous avons près dans
la schizophrénie donc il faut faire
attention avec mes gamins mais là c'est
notre rôle à nous de parents nous
parents dans le public parmi les
auditeurs nous devons faire attention à
ce que nos gamins regardent comme
messages sur les réseaux sociaux moi
avec ma femme depuis toujours j'explique
à mes enfants à faire le tri vous avez
ouvre les réseaux sociaux et qu'il faut
faire gaffe à pas avaler n'importe quel
n'importe quel médecin sur l'avenir pas
eva elle a déconné elle s'est excusée
mais on a tous un rôle qui est de ne pas
laisser nos gamins avaler les messages
des des influences euse même quand ce
sont des influenceurs qui gagnent des
centaines de milliers d'euros par mois
alors elle a alors au vu de la polémique
maeva elle s'est excusée elle a réagi un
jour plus tard regardez je tiens à
m'excuser parce que je me suis très mal
exprimé
faut savoir que voilà parfois quand je
parle l'info et passe pas par le cerveau
elle passe directement par la mouche ce
que j'ai dit c'est très grave je
m'excuse sincèrement pour vous
connaissez je sais que je suis par des
millions de personnes tout ce que je dis
ça de l'impact je n'ai pas fait je n'ai
pas fait refaire mon vagin j'ai fait du
laser et de la mésothérapie sans
injection pas ce que je fais de la cire
au niveau du maillot et je me suis brûlé
le maillot donc pour soulager ma douleur
j'ai tout la tête tout le corps qui
refait mais mon vagin non je n'ai jamais
fait de chirurgie esthétique un bon
vagin vagin il va très bien j'ai 24 ans
j'ai un beau vagin il est très beau ça
crée des
décors on est content de le savoir est
important il ya beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui se posaient la
question n'est pas tant ils sont
rassurés oui mais non mais qui doit vous
dit une bêtise pardon mais c'est que
aujourd'hui effectivement mais le tas il
centrait ils influencent beaucoup de
gens 3 millions de personnes elles
disent pro morceau mise parce que c'est
bien mais à l'époque que t es pas les
influenceurs c'était par des magazines
et les gamins regardent et des magazines
qui était photoshopée et à regarder des
monnaies chose n'allait pas d'épée même
chose et c'est tout il y avait moins de
conneries sur elle en 1966 du tout bio
sur instagram mal et cette
idée ce tir et les garçons je te donne
très souvent raison mais là c'est toi
qui déconne voilà alors on va pas non
plus relate toute la coise instagram
toute la nouvelle génération sur le dos
de maeva quand même parce qu'elle fait
parce que je trouve ma ci parce que
j'aimerais qu'on va sur le sujet l'aller
cheryl est ce que vous regardez bien la
vidéo est prévue à simon reste sujette à
vivre est-ce que vous avez bien regardé
la vidéo la première vidéo il ya un
chirurgien derrière elle c'est moi qui
dis rien qui parle pas et en dessous il
a écrit envoyé lu un message privé avec
son 06 est ce que ça vous trouvez que
les professionnels donc on s'en prend à
maeva mais beaucoup alors est évalué
pour moi il est derrière fond je serais
même pas le populaire j'avais non mais
le court ce qui ne savait même pas
qu'elle se retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux il est effondré il va avoir non
mais souple et oui arrêter les ennuis
avec le conseil de gérance et voros ça
suffit là ils savaient même pas le
pauvre s'est retrouvée sur une vidéo il
savait même pas où il y aurait ce qui me
choque c'est les dérives et
l'interprétation de ses propos qui est
fait on dit qu'elle veut rajeunir son
vagin donc qu'elle incite les jeunes à
faire ça à puce elle a jamais fait ça
elle a juste fait une épilation qui
s'est mal passé elle a fait une
opération de la mise au terme qui n'est
pas une opération d'ailleurs chien
s'hydrater et donc suite à ça elle a été
un peu maladroite elle a été sans filtre
comme beaucoup de candidats téléréalité
et les gens aiment les candidats télé
réalité pour ça elle a dit une connerie
elle l'a reconnu les foires et est lui
tombé de suite commencé à parler de
pédophilie j'ai eu son agent à magali
bertin cet après midi elle m'a dit tu
sais même pas ce que c'est la pédophile
a dit elle a dit la pédophilie gpk
normal quand
un pays accro avec senna pays bas il
voit que ce sont des gens qui filment
leurs journées pendant aller 10 heures
sur 24 qui disent comme tout le monde
des conneries pendant la journée ça leur
arrive elle a dit une connerie elle
s'excusait fin de l'histoire non mais
c'est vrai que la philosophie ni c'est
extrêmement grave je le dis il ya
vraiment des trucs très graves qui se
passe on en a déjà parlé sur ce plateau
et c'est vrai que il faut faire
attention quand on compare à ce genre de
choses parce que je sais que valérie
vous ça vous a un peu choqué voilà
mais c'est vrai que l'on pense qu'il
faut faire attention à ça donc je vois
effectivement et bien sûr que dans son
propos elle n'a pas cherché à choquer
qu'elle a été extrêmement maladroite et
arrêterons pas là elle est immédiatement
mais encore une fois elle a une
responsabilité faut qu'elle fasse alors
justement on à anouk à gonesse mettre à
nu car à gonesse qui étaient avec nous
ce soir c'est l'avocate de maeva ghana
merci à nuuk merci m d'être avec nous en
ce sens ça va bien
c'est bien vous êtes en sept emplois car
vous êtes en prison le coin
je suis je suis dans une forme on va
très bien j'ai envie de vous dire déjà
chadha thomas parce que je crois que
voilà qu'est ce qu'est ce que madame
quelques miles merci qu'est-ce que maeva
vous a dit au sujet de cette polémique
parce qu'elle a été touchée même bien
sûr qu'elle a été touchée elle est assez
sensible aux réactions et c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs keller l'instant des
décalages elle a percuté en réalité que
que ces propos ont pu choquer elle a
tout de suite pris son téléphone elle a
tenu à s'excuser elle a compris que ses
propos qui avaient été déplacées
ont suscité c'était moi et c'est pour
cela qu'elle a tenu à s'excuser
rétablir la vérité concernant les
injections les opérations la non
coopération
qu'elle qu'elle avait effectuée auprès
de ce médecin effectivement ce médecin
n'était absolument pas au courant que l
ce snap est en réalité
il n'avait pas mesuré les conséquences
et aujourd'hui ce médecin ben il vit
véritablement un acharnement parce que
depuis
les followers later n'ont pas de cesse
de le accablé alors qu'en réalité il n'y
est absolument pour rien et maeva bien
évidemment a pris la parole pour
informer sa communauté qu'elle avait
tenu des propos maladroits déplacer et
qu'en aucun cas elle n'avait souhaité
véhiculer les messages
d'incitation ne serait ce qu'à la
chirurgie alors il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont dit qu'elles aiment participer à
une certaine culture pédopornographiques
c'est ça qui a mis le feu aux poudres a
bien entendu après cette vidéo vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous l'ont alexandre
faut pas aller jusque là à aucun moment
elle ne fait d'incitation à la paix nos
graphiques mais en revanche on peut dire
qu'elle a été maladroite et qui ne faut
pas que nos adolescentes et des
obsessions corporelles à cause de
discours déplacer des influences yeuse
alors on a bien compris qu'elle s'est
trompée qu'elle n'a pas été opéré
qu'elle a eu juste des petits soins
locaux parce qu'elle avait des
démangeaisons elle s'est gouré elle
s'est excusée mais il faut quand même
pas inciter les influenceurs qui touche
des millions de personnes à donner des
obsessions corporelles à nos gamins
parce que c'est très grave à cet âge là
d'avoir des gamins qui sont obsédés par
le corps et celle assurée pour leur
développement psychologique
et on a des gamins qui évolue mal et qui
ont des pathologies psychiatriques parce
que ils se sont trop angoissé au moment
de la puberté pour leur corps donc
l'affairé est terminée il faut qu'elle
fasse gaffe il faut globalement que les
influenceurs cantilienne des propos de
nature médicale ne disent pas des
conneries comme maeva on a très
maladroitement dit lors de cette affaire
alors elle s'est exprimée avec magali
bernard à son agent regardez ça m'a fait
beaucoup de peine ils sont partis dire
que je me suis redevenu vierge alors que
c'est pas vrai j'ai juste mis du laser
pour rajeunir va revenir mais ils disent
que je me suis dit alger est ce que tu
peux leur dire que je suis pas parti me
recoudre l'hymen et me revient j'ai je
sais que je fais du laser c'est tout et
de la lumière pulsée
vie leur
jeu pas liège
[Rires]
c'était quand même là c'était quand même
important de le préciser pour les tester
à nancy vous pouvez lancer dans sur un
dossier s'est également exprimée
regardez à ses côtés deux fois
d'ailleurs avec magali mais voilà
regardez
déjà ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que bien évidemment que ces propos là
elle n'aurait pas dû les tenir c'est une
jeune fille de 24 ans qui n'a pas du
tout conscience de l'impact qu'elle peut
avoir sur les gens parce que maija est
une jeune fille simple elle ne mesure
pas les choses qu'elle peut dire ça peut
avoir un impact très très important vous
savez il ya des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux qui attaque beaucoup les autres
il ya des gens qui kiffent ont aussi des
choses très graves qui disent des choses
très graves mais souvent voilà ça passe
pour laisser passer l'orage et on oublie
maeva elle elle ne laisse pas passer
l'orage alors
voilà sans avocat et libertés presse
alors c'est son agent but est de nous
car la colère des familles avec des
enfants sean je me dis que il faut tout
soit supervisée dans les propos qui vont
s'unir ouais c'est très clair sinon ces
dérives là on les paye nous de nos
cabinets envoie des adolescents c'est
vrai qu'ils auraient à subir ça c'est
pas
non mes devoirs il est comme ça à 18 ans
maintenant il faut refaire les lèvres
tout ça c'est un résultat ou le fait ça
vous n'entendez ni lire au tout en
concédant mi temps mais je suis désolé
moi je me souviens d'un reportage
d'envoyé spécial pour la gagne et qu'on
disait non qu'ils voyaient arriver des
gamineries cancon choper des trucs porno
dossier de l'internât qui viennent
effectivement vous avez raison avec leur
mère et les gamines demande à ce qu'on
leur fasse l'amour parce que je vois
bien que ma vue le valais papa je pas
des biens dans les mains des maires des
villes veulent elles sont teintes elles
soient gros si elles ont des objections
donc c'est un ces catastrophes sont vus
mais c'est comme ça les prêts se fout
tout un filtre là pour parler à l'écran
le second se sont en outre blessées mais
c'est pas ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
une espèce de dictature
donner un vrai sens bien parce que pour
elle le fils c'était le café à l'époque
un oui
magali baird a est très gentil mais nous
prend pour des jambons parce que quand
elle est jolie bague et non mais elle
nous dit elle est au courant de rien se
rend pas compte de l' influence cas là
arrêtons de très bien l'influent ce cas
là elle c'est bientôt les gens qui la
suivent moi pardon encore une fois je
suis un peu comme valérie sans doute une
question génération et peut-être parce
qu'on est mère de famille j'ai été très
choqué par ces propos parce que je pense
que ça détruit complètement le rapport
qu'alcon les jeunes filles avec leur
corps mais aussi les garçons parce qu'il
faut pas emmener cas les gars ici qui
sont aujourd'hui obsédé par cette
représentation du corps de la femme
parfaite et pardon excusez moi à 12 ans
vierge d'accord alors on mettra nous car
gonesse quand vous entendez géraldine
maillet qui a été extrêmement choquée
que ce que vous lui répondez
je réponds que tout simplement on sait
peser aujourd'hui si on m'avait vague nm
une responsabilité qui ne lui incombe
appelé lui manque pas c'est une
influence 16 elle partage son quotidien
avec ses followers alors elle est très
spontanée
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'elle est
aimée aujourd'hui on peut pas faire
peser sur elle une responsabilité on est
dans une ère où les réseaux sociaux
c'est le quotidien de de tout le monde
et pour autant on a aucune
réglementation applicable on est dans
une zone de non-droit et aujourd'hui
elle n'est absolument pas en a aucune
difficulté sur le fait d'évoquer les
sujets dont elle souhaite qu'elle
souhaite aujourd'hui on peut pas lui
reprocher et sujets sociétaux madame
odile et d'hélicos d'accord avec vous
peut-être d'accord quand même que le
deux ans c'est quand même très choquant
ben là c'est comme cela que l'adhésion
des sacs elle a fait une autre vidéo on
va pas revenir là dessus car oui ça peut
en aucun cas si vous trouvez vous pouvez
vous pouvez faire ce lien en dix ans et
ses propos ainsi c'est une incitation à
la chirurgie à la pédophilie c'est
dramatique d'en venir non venir à tenir
ces propos promettez vous trouvez que
c'est disproportionné m maintenant
disproportionnée c'est totalement
disproportionné et c'est grave parce que
dans ces cas-là ça voudrait dire que
tous les placements que ce que les
enfants se reposent soeurs ont des
conséquences sur dramatique c'est pas ça
c'est simplement un partage d'ailleurs
ce n'était absolument pas aux huit
partager avec sa communauté une
expérience qu'elle avait vécu et donc
effectivement elle a fait de façon
maladroite déplacés elle a reconnu ses
torts mais pour autant on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui que elle a certes pesé
en tout cas sur elle et sur d'autres
influenceurs et réponse s'est
responsabilisé là où bien il faut
absolument réglementer les réseaux
sociaux
provoquer le débat pour l'offre que
qu'on puisse
réglementer légiférer là dessus ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas aujourd'hui